so my question is if we're giving  but I I don't give advice and that's  what I'm saying like my channel is  entertainment so you're saying give  advice why don't you give it but like  that's not what I do  if we're two human beings I just want to  know what's true what's untrue so and  you could you could say like are the and  the point is the laws are bad for men we  don't even disagree on this but but  you're like you got like I want to tell  you guys how to do your channel  like that's that and I mean you told me  that last time when you're telling me  how to do wife school and that's what  like a lot of people in in the on the  other side will criticize us and be like  well you should do it this way you  should do it this way but our job a lot  of people is entertainment mine is  mainly entertainment other people have  entertainment and education it just  depends on the channel